WEEK FOR MAJ CNI
WITHNETFLIAN
G
NO.
CN
TH AFTMATUNEWSS
ANERYONE INVOLVED.
S ELOPMENT THE DRAIN.
REDS OF STAF ME LAID
OFF, THOUGH E MPTRYING
T
OF IT.
PARTS ARE BELIEVING THEINTS ABG
POINTS BUT THE TTH THIS
A CORPORE MOVE.
THIS C PLUS SERVICWAS DOOMED
BECAUSE OF T
LASHING STRATEGIES.
THE NES PLANS E STREAMING
FO
CHALLENGER FOR NETFLIX.
ANEAKING OF WHS EK
INT.
NA SUBSCRIBE DECLINING
THE PANDEMICURGED.
AND NOS ABOUWHETHEIT MIGHTT
PANEL OF E FISHER, AOR
CORRESPOND
EPOLERIT.
E GUEST ONN W, SO THANK
YOU.
SERVICDOOMED VY TRANSPARENIT.
CNN PLUSS EXECUTIVES BEEN OTTIN
T THEY FIN WITE  TO  ONE
G RVAINMENT.
N S A
VICE.
MERGER LETED EY THOUGHT THIS I
OUTSIDER LOOKINGON
BUSINESS? R TH
>> IT'S CERTAINLOCIN
OF THERE THAT PR
TALKING 00MARKETING OTIONS, BIGR
SO IT  I BRUPTLY.BUT ATTHIS S .
THERE AR
ETOULD
S A  V
IFO OR FOWORSE.
TO YOUR POINT AS THE N O
OU AWOCONTINUEO ONEY AFTER APPE
THE BESTTERM IES
THE COMPANY.
I'M VERYURE WHAT W
FOLLOWINGS.WITH HUGE
WHERE WILL THEY GO?
>> I H SOURCY EVERYB P AND THE W
ISVEHAT
THAUNCHED STREAMING SERVICES
KE ESPN PL BUT
COLLEAGUES BNGD OFF THIS W
THH,S.
AND THERE'S SO D
IT WAS
SUCCESSFE NOW?
NT IS UNPRECEDENTED,
OUT.EDENT THIS WILEAS AND
KW  WEEKS OF LAD
SUBSCRIBS.YOU'REN NT THE PLANEST
TO SPEND A BILLA
PEOP A9 OR $99FITABILITYEARS.E I
K  LRTEN
SAID WN'IT WIL THED.'S GOOD NUMR
NOT BE A GOO
BUVER, WHAT'S NEXT F
>> CNN A
NENN H.COMIN, THE
00 P.M. HOST TO APT. HASO FIGU O
WITH THE TALENT  W
THE WNYINGO ABSOOMOP>> RIGHT. H
HU SHE HASF HE'S GOING TLACE CN
TO THE NIX S
THERE WAA HUGEAMWES SOTHE IN>> E
SUMIO PUTH
T  NOT BAS AS IT
OVR NSWILLING TO SUS A H RI
BUT THATNCREASS THHEADNES
>> IT IS.EIN
EVEN TH
EMAND
INCREASED POINT OF INFLATION, R
AT T OPPOSWHAT CNN PLUS.CNN PL
SUBSCRONNETFLIX TEN  FINALLYAM
CLUD